the story is for the past three years
i've been trying to go on a date with
sophia wow absolutely
unsuccessfully yeah wait a minute i'm
like oh for five can i go on a date yeah
yay what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to a
very special exciting episode of the
unwax podcast with your favorite sisters
sistine and
sophia you said your name first well i
got to do the intro first too because
you messed up today so
i'm in the doghouse i'm taking rain all
right i don't mean to and i feel really
bad that this happened so
just explain i'm so embarrassed because
i hate messing up if you know me i'm a
perfectionist i don't like making
mistakes especially when it's on
sistine's time as well because she will
give me [ __ ] for the next
week i had to cancel my appointment
because of your little time her facial
the one time i decided to treat the one
time that's true she doesn't do facials
thank you but um
definitely screwed the pooch on this one
i thought the guests were coming now but
they're coming in uh four hours so
we're a little early but thank you guys
for all being here um i know that i had
to
rush this morning and you did too and it
was awesome it's great
i'm sorry i i will i'll make it up to
you you know what though i actually
really enjoyed doing the intro today
maybe i should do this more often
is that the deal that you take the intro
now i would like to rotate sometimes all
right
she'll take the intro you guys can tell
us if you like minor parts better oh
yeah leave it to the commenters i love
it okay so i feel like last week's
episode
we had a lot of things that we wanted to
discuss but forgot to bring up yeah i
don't know why we just completely didn't
even right we didn't write it down we
just didn't remember it brain fog brain
fog that's right
totally i think at this time maybe
halloween has passed i'm assuming right
yes yeah i wonder how that's going
future me is like i really hope it went
well yeah i'm hoping that i got my um
halloween hookup what did it what else
did i say october orgasm that's true
i like to every single year think of a
funny way to like twist in a holiday
with like something about yeah making
out
i actually remember i used to do sober
october yeah oh you didn't do that i
don't know why it stopped why would you
i think october is kind of a festive
month in some ways even though it's just
like it's only halloween yeah speaking
of scary vibes you were discussing that
you wanted to get lasik eye surgery oh
yeah so i don't know if anyone else has
contacts they're the worst because they
hurt your eyes if you get an eyelash in
it you get fuzz in it they hurt if
you're sleeping they dry in your eye and
then you can't take it out oh
this was one of the worst things my dad
one time this is like
we're on our way
courtside to a basketball game oh it's
epic it's subtle flex i'm fully flexing
everyone would be wanting to do that and
while i'm on the way there
my contacts pop out of my eye and this
idiot didn't bring any backups she's
pointing to herself not me me sophia is
the idiot i watched two hours of a
basketball game that i couldn't see
literally when i say my eyesight is fuzz
i can't see the player so i'm watching
sistine's head turning left and right so
then i'm not the idiot looking right
when everyone's looking left because i
can see anything so
i have come to decide that i don't want
to keep doing this anymore and i want to
get lasik eye surgery have you seen
youtube videos yes i don't know if i can
do it i don't know i can tell you why i
want you to do it why
because i'm pretty sure for a full 24 or
48 hours you have to be blind
with goggles
this is going to be so much fun for me
yeah so same keeps saying she wants to
do taste testing with me
and not know like feed me things i don't
know what your other senses are going to
be heightened maybe i'll start tickling
your skate and you won't know hours it's
going to be like 80 hours of me like
figuring out okay my senses are low but
i just want to like rig your room with
like little sound machines and just
scare me that was such a dick move i
know don't do that do i have to bathe
you
ew says you know i just shot her myself
i'm not like you're blind how can you
shower yourself you can cl oh wait when
you put your head under the water in the
shower you close your eyes and assuming
it sounds like you're gonna slip
i didn't actually i slept in the shower
this morning i have a huge bruise on my
calf
so who knows what it's gonna be like
when i can't see but i don't like the
idea because what it is is you have to
peel off
this like very very small layer of eye
skin yeah
delicious pupil skin pupil skin uh
what's the term not your their corneas
in the back but i don't know what the do
you think cannibals like eyeballs as
well
i feel like they're like boba when they
eat it do you think army hammer would
eat an eyeball
what he what
did he he didn't eat people did he
yeah no i thought i thought
wait i actually didn't chew like his
girlfriend's arm a little bit or
something so we didn't choose
girlfriend's arm off like no he took a
little nibble i thought he was just into
oh god we i have to research this maybe
he did eat something
right back he did should we call him
speaking of eating and cooking
good transition i
have decided
that i'm gonna plan a date
and i also decided that i'm gonna cook
on said date yeah that's a lot of
pressure
it is a terrible idea and now that i've
already suggested it to the guy he's
very much into this idea
and i've realized that i can't cook
anything besides chicken and microwave
rice you can also saute some broccoli
i've seen it how do you saute broccoli
what do you mean how do you saute
broccoli put broccoli you gotta boil it
first see these are things i don't even
know
oh i don't know that part see and then
sofia goes you should make chicken parm
yeah i did say that to him and he was so
into it chef boyardee i need to make
chicken pork isn't it just chicken the
souffle sauce and cheese you literally
have to pout you have to slice the
chicken
pound it yep bread it with flour and
then you have to make yes and then you
have to dip it in eggs dip it back in
flour dip it in bread crumbs see if this
is your date buy it put it in a pan it's
like are you joking but if that's your
date it's cooking wouldn't you want to
choose something that's a bit more fun
and different why would you choose
chicken and rice you can just order that
from panda express what's the difference
i used to love panda express i did two
until i realized the sodium until i
realized that i couldn't fit in my jeans
do you remember like when you were a kid
you just had whatever you felt like
yeah i can't the things i didn't worry
about i had super pretzel
like at least twice a day you ate a
frozen pretzel every day your she ate it
frozen
it's great i naught on it every day
no but i feel like it's a good idea i
think if you go into cooking something
that is
you know what's the easiest thing pasta
just make pasta pink sauce pasta get
some chicken cut some chicken put in the
pasta you know what i'm nervous about
honestly this is sounding a lot of uh
like a lot of red sauce right now i'm
scared of getting heartburn oh that's a
that's fair that's fair i get acid
reflux and i have too much
so because that happens so many times
i'll go on a date and then i start
getting severe heartburn i'm like
where's the next and he also doesn't
like tomatoes except when they're
blended so maybe tomatoes isn't the
thing you're going for
i also had um a bathroom thought today
um on the toilet
no but tmi
maybe it was but i won't tell
that's a secret i'll never tell
xoxo tina uh
i had a shower thought today and i was
like am i
unlovable
me out
i feel like every time i start to like
stop giving me that face
i feel like every time
i start to like someone i start to
self-sabotage and find things that are
wrong with them when there's actually
nothing wrong with them because i have
to
find reasons that it's not going to work
and i don't deserve love
that's some type of bathroom thought you
had going on there you know what that is
true on you you do do that a lot well
adele's been putting me in my feels easy
on me is making me no but you do that
and that's i feel like a lot of people
can relate to that it's having a
vulnerability issue it's you're not able
to fully let yourself go you can be as
you i like to explain as you are very
outspoken you almost are the most open
book but closed off person you'll ever
meet you'll say everything but say
nothing it's true you know like you'll
talk a lot you'll make them laugh you'll
make it interesting but you won't
actually because give them the thing
they want to take the next 100 and i
hate when
someone tells me that i'm saying oh i
have you figured out like i can read you
yeah bothers me i want to be completely
unreadable or at least still a little
bit of a mystery to them because i feel
like the second they have me entirely
that like they're going all the control
is lost but you know it's like the
opposite because when you actually give
your heart to someone i feel like they
want to actually be with if you've set
it up to be that way no but you and i do
this too is i find every reason that
like every wrong thing about them even
if it's not a problem like i will say
that they didn't cut their chicken
twelve times they cut it eleven times
that's some ocd that's that's that's
that's that's that's that's fine
i'm not actually saying to someone they
didn't cut their chicken enough um now
i'm on this food thought because of the
cooking thing but you're not unlovable
you just are scared to be
loved
and we'll be right back no i'm just
kidding
no it's true well i clicked but you know
i think that's been like this since
we've been single for a while we're not
used to like
you know that actually turns this
thought i was saying to sistine was that
i
feel like
it's what was it that we were saying it
was something about dating that
oh my god we were just saying this
christine oh wait wait give me you have
a moment to think i'll tell you this
though i think that this type of
mentality isn't something that you just
have one day i truly think that it only
takes one maybe bad or toxic
relationship to give you this
mind frame yeah like i feel like my
worst relationship was when i was 19
you know who you are i know who you are
too
uh and
yeah i was 19 and i'm 23 and i still
deal with
how that person made me feel and then
you never forget it no and then you
assume the things that your next person
are doing even if it's
they forgot to do something or they said
something that's different and it just
makes you remember that moment that you
had when you were 19 and you're like
that they're gonna do the same thing
when that's not the case it's so hard
you have to be able to when you're in a
new relationship and i feel this way
completely separate the last person you
were dating to the new person you're
dating i know i compare everything like
they're the same because every i feel
like when you fall in love with someone
new you fall in love with different
things like
you're throwing this l word out
but when you're dating or falling in
love whatever it is
you're gonna love this person for a
completely different reason that you
loved the other person for you know so
you can't compare it but this is
actually i just remember what it was uh
that i was saying was that i get shocked
when people hit on me
remember how i said that
and i know you guys are out there like
sophia showed up
luck
look at a mirror sweetheart thank you
but i'm not saying this to get anything
at all i'm just telling you the truth i
feel like because i grew up and not i
was not the hot kid you know me i was
wearing a flash drive on my neck i had
braces i had an ugly betty haircut my
glasses were pointed up like 50s style
and i did shot put so you know i wasn't
the and they were pants every day sophia
wasn't the pick of the litter that you
wanted no one was like talking about me
on ask f i was uh
sophia was
uh ugly buddy yeah i was we were called
i susan
you know who thought of the ugly betty
comment it was sistine yeah but everyone
thought i was a boy like the first 15
years of my life goldfish for pokemon no
no i wore
i wear knee-highs
what are you guys laughing at
i had
i had side bangs not like a little side
bang like a full justin bieber thick
side bang
and short hair and i wore animal print
knee socks yeah with converse two
different colored converse every day and
you used to buy your bottom lip so it'd
swell up so also i had uh mosquito bites
everywhere
no meaning my boobs
oh but you always get bit that's why i'm
kind of oh yeah no i wasn't talking
about she didn't have no tits so i
literally looked like a board like a
plank yeah and all i did was do track
and and play flag football and i was
just so
i looked like at least you didn't sign
up for a talent show
playing basketball on stage scene yeah i
was part of the chess club i was part of
the chess club we were pull the part of
the chest i collected cats but this is
the thing is that sistine i'll tell you
i made a journal of different breeds of
cats
this is the extent of when a guy likes
us no guys actually had crushes on this
when we were growing up at all like
actually more guys were writing like uh
drawing drawings of you remember that
kid it's like the opposite oh
yeah the amount
here's a perk of getting of being the
weird kid you always get a weird kid's
stalker liking you in school as well
there was always that one kid in school
that was like okay
this one's a little bit of a suspicious
individual right
i had two instances of that
in high school i had this weird kid that
never spoke do you remember what was
that um wedding crashers and the brother
in it is like the guy that draws the
whole thing that was him that was that
was him and all he would do is draw me
from the back of the classroom and one
day i was walking by his book and i go
holy holy [ __ ] i did a double take ago
that's me and i said does that mean he
goes no and slams the book and runs away
the next day i go can you show me that
drawing he goes it's for you gives it to
me the last day of school
this is crazy and signs it another kid
drew a photo with knives in my stomach
in fourth grade yeah it was that was
i would be like i see you i'm outside
your house and i was like garrett
stop here
get out if he's watching this he's still
like no but this this brings it back to
i i really didn't get hit on until a lot
later in life and so still today like i
feel like i still have that mentality of
that kid i was back then yeah and if you
know sistine and i on that deeper
personal level we're actually the
biggest goofs and weirdos ever we make
impersonations we like honestly we dress
up in the weirdest way like we don't
like to do anything but make fun of each
other and when a guy comes up to me and
hits on me or is interested in me i will
say that that is completely false and
that's not true
you did that the other day i did the
other day and they were totally vibing
with this guy at a bar and i was like
sophia obviously he likes you because he
wouldn't waste his whole night talking
to you if he didn't and you were
completely worried about sitting on
yourself and [ __ ] on yourself and
like why would you like me you're lying
i was like my hair's flat why are you
like me
no it's so it's i just feel like i need
it's also a confidence thing i think
that when you go from just like not
getting that attention a lot when you're
growing up i feel like a lot of the
girls that were like the pretty ones in
high school they always they were able
to they feel like that's why when they
grow up they think they're still the
[ __ ] and then when they're not it's true
it's like it i'd rather be this guy's
like completely ignorance is blessed
like
i agree it's almost like going back to
how
one person in a relationship can harm
the way you feel in other relationships
later on it's the same thing when you're
growing up you still see yourself as
ugly buddy i do
i don't think so but it's i just need to
stop because i'm not saying this once
again to like get any sympathy from
people but i think she is
everyone tell me how pretty i am no but
i feel like people can relate to this if
they weren't the cool kid in school and
then they got older and they kind of got
their groove or style down and represent
they're still it's like hard for them
almost to flirt sometimes because they
just don't assume that that person would
be interested but
you know i gotta get over that you
definitely gotta get over that because
we have
two males joining us today on the show
so strap in baby actually we should talk
about what we did with them yesterday
yeah yeah so i don't know if you guys
have heard of the hilarious meme page i
would call it a meme page maybe but
they're they were social media platforms
yeah i mean it's grown from some that to
now it's big and they're getting deals
but it's called friday beers and it is
so genius these two comedian writers
these two brothers actually there's
three of them there's three of them yeah
um but we're gonna have two on today and
they have created this
this instagram page into this massive
right i'll sort of explain it in greater
detail to the listeners if you guys are
living under a rock and you don't know
what friday beers is please check it out
yeah do yourself a favor and look it up
right now but basically it's a social
media platform production company and
lifestyle brand so they have merch and
all they do is make sketch comedy videos
based off of you know like relatable
topics such as various movies too yeah
such as working in nine to five and the
whole concept is
that you are
that guy or girl in the office and
you're just itching for that beer on a
friday and you're
waiting for that friday to come so you
can take the edge off and have that
release exactly so they've sort of made
this whole brand around that concept and
feeling and it is hysterical so we have
these brothers coming on joining us
today i think it's going to be a lot of
fun we went on theirs yesterday and it
was hilarious so now we have a better
idea about what to ask him and you guys
this is going to be an episode that's
completely different from the other ones
we've done so stay tuned
[Music]
unwaxed listeners joining us today we
have two very talented guys who are both
somewhat responsible for our hangover
today thank you very much they are
brothers venice beach nomads and social
media savants who are the masterminds
behind the fast-growing platform known
as friday beers we have max and jack
barrett yes
random applause studio audience thank
you yeah
thank you guys so much for coming on the
show today i don't know how we somehow
tricked you guys thanks for having us
well you call this a savant and
mastermind in the same i've never been
called that ever and a nomad yeah
i've never been this flattered really i
can tell you're glowing and radiant yeah
inside okay that's great we actually
brought we got we brought you guys
presents too
yeah we brought you guys
friday beers merch you don't have to
wear it wait wait wait wait presents we
brought you presents it's a gift
exchange
oh my god christmas came early yeah here
we go i'll take this
you can pick one can i can i yeah
oh perfect
so i used to write ads for patron did
you explain it brings me back to my
early uh l.a days oh love to get into
your early ladies and they never gave me
free patrons they didn't really you
would think that they would do that for
like
discounts and all you had to do was come
on the unwaxed podcast to get free
patrol who knew who at three o'clock
sharp i just needed it i did screw up
the timing that was my bad yeah sofia
[ __ ] the schedule but yesterday we did
join you boys on the uh friday beers
podcast when is that coming out uh tbd
okay probably november probably november
i have to say sophie and i went on their
show and we were discussing it all last
night all this morning
we had the most you guys crush it i was
that was you guys questions those
questions were awesome yeah well those
that's all this isn't insulting but
you're a lot funnier than i thought you
would because we get that all the time
well i don't know seriously we do get
that i get you're not as [ __ ] as i
thought you were wow you are nice
you have rbf okay yeah i think a lot of
people think we're not scared that's
like the best compliment you guys left
and we sort of looked around each other
like wow that was like kind of electric
like you guys why
i knew sophia was funny i've known you
yeah because we met because we like
we've we met a while ago so actually why
don't we get into that yeah
you were shocked when i brought that up
yesterday i hadn't put together the
pieces neither yeah yeah so why don't
you two elaborate yeah well it was at
the beach club with claire yeah the
story is for the past three years i've
been trying to go on a date with sophia
wow absolutely
unsuccessfully yeah wait a minute i'm
like oh for five wait a minute wait
every six months i'll be like
yes that's fair yeah take us back let's
take it back so i remember what the one
thing you did tell me you were trying to
write comedy at the time right you were
trying to sell a script yeah and i
forgot where you were trying to pitch it
you asked me out i had recently just
broken up with my ex
and so much
college
you said you were in love there always
yeah and then as luck had it
years later
we i was on hinge for like three days we
were doing something for our production
changed like going nuts we were honest i
was on hinge and i was unhinged
right so while i was on it for the three
days i wasn't taking it seriously
because i was about to delete it i saw
him on it and guess who reached out
first
was it you it was me we gotta go back to
the table because he had
i think i said an anchorman quote to you
yeah i mean half of our attacks are just
like i'm sophia
i know okay well that's fair wait that
so i didn't realize that you guys had
met before matching on hinge yeah we've
met like so
every day full circle and now we're here
today and we never got our dates never
got our date well there's still time for
that
you've been asking consistently so yeah
oh
yes exactly
where would you like to take sofia on
your first date hypothetically
hypothetically hypothetically um
i mean a lot of good like fast casual
restaurants around here
maybe chili's
[Music]
any restaurant that has pictures of the
food on the menu you would definitely be
the person taking a cha-cha chicken uh
i've never been oh that's a great place
if you guys haven't been it's you bring
my bring your own beer yeah do you want
to go on a date yeah i'll confirm
yay
all right this is this is legally
binding
yeah
did you meet your wife on a dating app
that's funny actually because
um
i had matched with my
now wife on hinge no sorry
i misspoke
she saw me unhinged and x to me yeah no
the first time she saw me yes i promised
it wasn't good enough yeah tell me what
was her reasoning behind that she was
just like nah i'm not feeling it right
now
and so she left
it's like extra check i don't know what
it was back in 2015 but
she denied me and then we ended up
meeting in person like three or four
weeks later and uh we struck up from
there and she was like yeah i'm actually
the owner of the halloween party right
at a halloween party
it was almost
it was almost seven years ago weren't
you like uh waldo or something i was uh
where's waldo so how could she find you
that's right that's a good choice i know
a good question
yeah yeah that means something okay so
that's sort of sounding like this
situation that's happening over here
right i know
i mean halloween's approaching
do you have a costume yet waldo
maybe seven years from now you guys will
be married wait so okay oh look you guys
matched on him not really which is great
you mad at a halloween stop flirting you
two you met at a halloween party
and
now you got married about three weeks
ago we got yeah three weeks ago we got
married and um her name was olivia by
the
way
barrett my last name yeah
didn't even think about any hyphenated
stuff she's like not she was in it she
was like
yeah what if it was what if she said no
i would have taken her last name
what's her last name banic it sounds
very good
and i'm progressive i'm actually very
progressive so no no remember i told you
i was gonna uh inseminate again oh yeah
we said that um pregnant guys could be
kind of hot yeah yeah and he said he
would be a hot pregnant guy you would be
hopping
we got i got married in the adirondacks
it's like upstate new york like pretty
close to canada she's actually canadian
oh so she's friendly she's super
friendly and there's a lot of canadians
at the wedding
everyone was so friendly
how are canadians partying actually
they oh how are they yeah are they like
are they fun at weddings are they crazy
are they partying we actually so we got
the we got the news that the
saturday of the wedding was the single
highest bar revenue day
in the history of the club where we had
the wedding no are you serious it's a
proud honor so to say the least you guys
got absolutely
yeah it was awesome uh everyone had a
great time the wedding like perfect
weather went off without a hitch then i
went to mexico for um our honeymoon how
was that i got covered on the second day
of the honeymoon where in mexico were
you
that's why nice i think
he went to squid row
yeah i had um everyone had needed to be
fully vaccinated at the wedding and we
requested tests so people like in theory
got tested and they showed us their
tests
and i found out on the wednesday this
day after we got to our honeymoon that i
was like i had 101 degree fever so i got
tested i had it called my called my dad
he was like well not only do you have it
your brother sam has it your uncle has
it your aunt has it and your
grandparents who is the culprit do you
find out
we can't name it you can't say it you
find out he's not going to watch it but
we think it was my uncle
he was even more nuts oh my god mother
god wait are your grandparents
thankfully the only thing i cared about
is that they were gonna be okay okay and
they are totally fine now they didn't
get symptoms as bad as like i had
symptoms yeah um but those are the only
six people who got it at the whole
wedding oh i don't know no one else
are in within our family
[Laughter]
trapped in the room and i could taste
smell and i didn't feel [ __ ] i would
just got drunk and ate it yeah exactly
totally fine but i i felt [ __ ] well no i
got the same exact symptoms because i
was that was in february for me and so
all i did was like take tequila shots i
couldn't taste anything i'm like wow
this is amazing yeah i mean it's like
water yeah it was like water it was
freaky it's one of the more bizarre
experiences to have you you're it's just
disconnected what's going on i haven't
talked to anybody about this but have
you did you feel it going away like the
feeling of it leaving or did you wake up
i could feel it slowly going away that
was the weirdest part because i woke up
like yeah it was the weirdest thing ever
but um glad i have it back because i was
worried because a lot of people have
been saying they don't get it back for a
month that's what i'm saying i got it
back in like two days
so it
i hate cilantro like i would vomit if i
tasted cilantro and i could take such a
[ __ ] around slime
what about cilantro
i just think it's like disgusting
i'm sorry i think there's a little
cilantro in my burrito
i sent it back
it's gross to me it's like foul i will
gag like olivia always is like you're
embarrassing me because you're sending
stuff back because that's a lot just
about the slogans
yeah guy that sends food and drink back
if it has cilantro oh yeah nothing else
that's the only reason it's not if it's
like undercooked like fine i'll just
have it right and cilantro aversion is
like a real genetic thing yeah oh really
it's
genetic like so certain people have
are
again this goes back to my advertising
days we did uh
campaign for
uh
was it 23 and me
yep that's it yeah i did that and like
you know like all the trades you can
yeah yeah yeah like my like you're like
wow i'm related to sylvester stallone
yeah
i have no idea 50 of it actually our
results were alarming
test is complete [ __ ] because all
all it tells you is like oh like your
eye color is brown like yeah i know
the one thing that's interesting is they
show you if you have a cilantro version
wow so it's like it's literally either
born like you can you're fine with
cilantro or it tastes like soap yeah do
they have one for eggs because i i gag
it for eggs yeah that's a tough thing to
hate
breakfast is so hard any type of egg
scrambled eggs all eggs oh smells
because my dad made her eat it with
ketchup so i think she's triggered that
he wanted me to get big when i was young
so he only fed me
anyway i
ironically
now you said you are trying to get big
oh yeah she does thought eggs is hard
yeah
what about egg whites yeah see any the
smell smells smell okay we're staying
off i want to discuss friday beers i
mean it's blown up obviously as you guys
know to such ex quick numbers i want to
know how it started yeah max was living
in l.a i was living in new york uh
we both worked in media and
entertainment in some form max was
writing patron ads who's that agency and
23andme yeah
i worked at like a media production
company so actually like made
commercials produce commercials and like
a lot of non-scripted film and tv stuff
and branded stuff so we're like writing
professionally yeah sort of
and we're always as you guys know like
comedy is the only thing that we kind of
like outside of
sports and just sort of hanging right
so we would we're like okay let's try
this independently right right sketch
comedy 27 comedy we will write comedy
scripts try and sell them nobody would
buy them
uh write feature ideas and we were going
for you know a couple years like having
yeah the animated show i pissed you or i
told you about you didn't get oh i'm
sorry yet to be greenlit yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's not the reason why i did say
no
i hope he was like well if you're
supposed to show me yeah
don't even have it you don't even have a
development deal
uh we were trying that for a while and
um we thought we stood by the stuff that
we thought was funny just like couldn't
really get like a big audience behind it
and then
at the end of 2019 we sort of made a
pact we're like all right we're gonna go
for it we're gonna like brand ourselves
like the barrett brothers we're gonna be
writers we're gonna write a new script
every single month and we're going to
aggressively try and like push them out
to people and then we're going to create
this instagram account for like a new
form of sketch comedy okay
that max really pioneered because he's
unbelievable video editor so he took all
those jokes and we just used other
people's content films tv shows like
write jokes on top of
and that ended up being what really
people really resonated with yeah it was
don't miss every single post that's what
you see in the comments no you don't oh
is it really is it that's the thing it's
so oh you know they always say you know
you don't miss what's the yeah
yeah the handshake
so the handshake started because we were
getting so many comments yeah and i
wanted to like respond to all of them
but i was like i can't write out a
response so i was like i'm just gonna
like shake their hand
so i just like did it like
not intending for it to become like now
basically like i'm kind of a meme in a
way the brand like yeah yeah part of the
brand is like the handshake and it's
very symbolic of what friday beers is
yeah right when we used to go on family
vacations before friday beers oh she
does choose
sorry our littlest brother sam he
co-founded friday beers with us as well
and he works on it he lives out here too
yeah we always forget to shout out sam
yeah sam
shout out
sammy beats a shirt says shout outs yeah
shout out to you
he and max whenever we'd go to places
would insist on getting a picture of
them quote sealing the deal
in front of like various landmarks so
like we went to paris like let's get the
seal the deal okay that we were here we
did it it's like yeah and i would just
pretend like we're like business man
like conducting a transaction it's so
funny so i would be taking the picture
and they would have like all these
handshake photos yeah you can see here
like subconsciously so it was meant this
yeah people listening that don't exactly
understand like when you say you're
writing scripts
yeah what does that mean when we wrote
scripts okay i'm almost done
these are colors there's a lot of photos
but i love it i'm a big guy you're a big
pudding carousel
yeah you are a big fan but then you
gotta sprinkle in some funny ones
where do you find those photos though i
just saw a photo of two people in front
of uh
yeah kissing after the uh the race and
the all-star game wait you did the shrek
tour yeah i wanted to do that
it took me to jack the ripper to her i
was like i want to do this
max had like a meltdown
i was so hungover
and like sam and i were wandering around
london we're like let's do like the
london eye and there's a huge line oh no
it takes forever let's do the shrek tour
yeah 100 i was like all right i'm like
you know when you're really hung over
like anxious yeah you're like shaking
like
going into the shrek tour and like
obviously like [ __ ] characters
popping out and like these little kids
running around
and i'm like dude i don't know i might
have to get off this ride like i'm
overwhelmed and like yeah it's like one
of those three 3d things where you have
that oh no 3d shrek is a badass did you
like throw up or something was it for no
i was like i i like couldn't move i was
like i'm terrified
how hungover were you really hungover oh
okay fair enough yeah we get pretty bad
hangovers do you um is it is it one of
those things because you drink too much
or it's just any alcohol it just makes
you feel like as you get older you just
get more hungover it's age is a factor
yeah ages factor anxiety is a factor and
then i think it's the type of alcohol
too yeah honestly like i don't my beer
hangovers are not nearly as bad as as
like for her drink hard liquor yeah no
honestly that's the juice that's good
you take that bad boy down yeah you
could do that yeah
when you guys decided to quit your
careers right throw everything at this
and hopefully the spaghetti stuck to the
wall what were your parents thinking
were they like uh well we didn't quit
for a while okay it was we sort of edged
into this okay over a period of time so
it wasn't as jarring and
uh it didn't really pick up like steam
steam until early 2021
and
and then march
2020.
well what year is it 2021 yeah okay all
right it's in march 2020. i remember
march 13th
uh was the day like the like the travel
ban like covid was like real
people like all like curled up in their
apartments or like went to their parents
house to go live there and that was when
we were like this thing's growing but
like yeah is this going to be
sustainable
it was like it was a very calculated
risk and i remember i actually quit my
job
like two weeks before the lockdown
happened oh and
friday
put him put in my two weeks and i was
like yeah friday beer is like
unstoppable like right you know people
were gonna start having live events it's
gonna be awesome
and so i was like told my agency like
[ __ ] you like i'm out right like we just
signed with wme i was like yo we're hot
[ __ ]
and
uh then like the travel ban
like the lockdown happened yeah and i
was like oh [ __ ] like i don't know yeah
i went back to my
boss and i was like can i get my job
done
it was a thumbs up
and he and he was nice enough he was
like yeah sure you can you know he's
like i'm not gonna you know kick you out
uh right before lockdown
so i went back to my job and then a
couple months later once we kind of
realized all right we can get through
this
weirdness um that's when i i quit like
you quit again july yeah
all right now
yeah so we were able to like be like
guys mom and dad like this is a
this is a real thing over the course of
this is not a hobby yeah and we also
proved to ourselves that it was okay
yeah it was more approving to ourselves
once we knew
uh
that we could like make a living off of
it right it became clear that there was
an upward trajectory
and we made yeah decisions like first it
was max and then actually sam and then i
was the beginning of this year although
it wasn't like our dad like doesn't
understand like social media that's why
we can relate but he has like he has
like weird like very like specific
uh and like weird references to like how
things work yeah and he's like you know
it could be gone in a
yeah
day
right
yeah
which is like kind of true
yeah that's true no it's true i mean our
parents when we first started the
podcast where they were supportive but
they're like oh you're just talking a
microphone about what boys they're like
okay
tell you things no one cares about yeah
like how do you make money off of this
this isn't a job it's a fun hobby yeah
we're probably like you know they're
right
this is gonna be the case
if we weren't making any money we're
like okay this is like first 20 episodes
we were just doing it as a hobby and
it's like oh now we're doing something
yeah i mean you have to put in those
reps though to make sure that lots of
wraps yeah lots of wraps
a common misconception about friday
beers is like
we just kind of started the account one
day like no prior experience and we kind
of just found like this golden ticket
right in reality like there were years
of practice training and writing and
developing these characters and these
jokes people have been talking about
friday beers for a long time is it oh
they're the only ones that we were
recontextualizing exactly you made a
thing yeah um and we used it as a thing
that
was
basically
basically a universe of like feelings
you have throughout the week right and
people that you hang out with like it's
all around the feeling of friday beers
yeah there's a lot of different ways you
can go with that i i mean i love it i
think it's so clever and funny
my question is
you know i have an issue where i think
i'm really funny but no one else thinks
i'm funny so how did you guys know that
your content was funny enough for people
to actually listen to it here's the
thing we all we always thought ourselves
were funny which is a nice thing to have
like yeah yeah we made each other laugh
and we made ourselves laugh actually i
i know how it actually happened i've
always thought jack was like the
funniest person ever oh
validate me like that
and i was like begging him for like
forever like dude god moved to l.a like
we gotta be making comedy together
i was like you know this isn't gonna
work without you and i've always just
kind of like
tried to emulate like jack's comedy and
like what i do
and then
i think there was like tearing up you
know
when
when i was able to get
when i felt validated by jack that's
when i was like oh [ __ ] like
like now like now we can really if i can
contribute the way jack contributes like
right we can really go go anywhere we
want with this
and when we were doing the sketch comedy
that's when i started to kind of build
confidence and
when i saw jack kind of
get interested in what we were doing in
l.a yeah i was like okay there's if jack
believes in it then like there's
something here there's something here
yeah and so that's kind of good it's a
good thing to go into like siblings
because now you guys work with each
other 24 7. we brought this up yesterday
yeah i mean we work live eat sleep talk
she hates when you chew yeah she hates
when i chew she hates when i come in the
room because i'm a morning person coming
to the room
i'm a morning person with coffee and
she's like literally cannot get out of
bed um
but
how has that been what's like the pros
and cons working with you like what's
the pro of it and what's the con of it
yeah working with your brother uh the
the pro is
to me is pretty obvious it's like the
short hand you have with your sibling
right it's like it's almost like
telepathic yeah that's so true you can
creatively especially like you know
the references you know how each other
are thinking when like you're writing
it could be efficient in that way very
efficient and then
i and like you're very comfortable with
each other but then that's the concept
you're too comfortable and you're all
like boundaries go too far yeah yeah
what's an example of a boundary that has
been blurred with you guys they start
like yelling at each other like in at
the office like in front of other people
like right that type of thing mm-hmm and
you kind of get get too personal too
fast yeah yeah
and then you guys are comfortable with
it though because it's like you guys are
brothers and stuff kind of i mean cece
and i will fight with each other but
we're used to the fighting but then no
one else is you guys you always make
little jokes and references like the
handshake stuff what is the deal with
hayley seinfeld and dua lipa because
when i was searching friday beers those
two names always came up after friday
and that's the only girl you follow is
haley yeah
it plays a big part in like the friday
mythology okay
so when we started the account
and it kind of took off really quickly
we kind of thought like you know who
should we follow because like
um
i think for the opportunity to make
another joke yeah
like what can be a story yeah you know
what actually
again you got a video no this goes back
to my advertising days i remember there
was a really funny
uh
restaurant
their instagram only followed like the
seven herbs and spices that they used
okay
are you serious yeah and i was like
that's like that's really clever so then
when we had this
account with his following i was like we
should do something like that right
and
we thought like let's have like as like
a celebrity crush
can kind of be a story line and we can
like try to like get their attention he
was yeah
and i remember
the reason why i didn't i had never
heard of her before 2019. yeah she was
sort of on the come up and then yeah
there's that haley or do i do
then there's a video came out of her and
she's like doing this dance on stage a
little hip oh like the horrible dancer
like she's like swaying a bit but like
it's like good it was good to us we
loved it you guys liked it she was
ripped on that she got ripped on but
yeah we loved it we put this like cool
song in the background okay like that we
really liked uh that you guys were the
one account that actually praised it
when everyone else is yeah i thought i
was like this is like really sexy like
it was like a it was like okay
so we're like
is our
goddess our queen well you said it was
what happened but then we found out she
was dating her boyfriend
oh so haley because she's single she's
basically your guys no because we didn't
abandon duallipa after that we just
basically tried to
make her break up with anwar of course
of course of course yeah three brothers
for the price how did you go overboard
i made fun of them a lot well like
whenever you did yeah she would like
post a photo of them too that's really
funny and like we would comment
something like
it wasn't initially wasn't very like it
wasn't super mean but it's just yeah
but like our comments were getting
thousands of likes from our followers
they were appearing in her top comments
no no like above like gigi hadid and
above like bella like it was literally
so like she obviously knew who you guys
were
at one point we were also selling
t-shirts on our website that just said
anwar sucks
in a weird way
i mean in a weird way if i was due i'd
be like i'm flattered
i don't know if you got it
yeah you could have anwar your boyfriend
or you could have
tens of thousands of horny 25 year olds
which one do you want choose one's more
loyal than the other so then when we
were blocked we uh you found hayley and
she's a multi-talented
singer
and we did a sketch with her how did you
guys get her oh well her her brother
griffin mm-hmm shout out griffin stein
shout out griffin
yeah it's kind of very coincidentally
and fortuitous yeah griffin had been
following us for a while i was a fan so
then when we announced like haley's are
like
our new pursuit and you guys didn't know
that you're live no
and one day
one day we remember we got a text from
like tons of people like go to haley
stefan's instagram account she posted a
video of her being like like this for
the friday's hat shut up
um so
we we uh saw the video like oh my god
like contact has been made like she has
acknowledged us
so we were able through um
just our our agents to like get to her
like publisher or publicist yeah and we
were like here's what friday beer is all
about yeah i think it's funny and yeah
and then we we sent her this script yeah
and we're like there's no [ __ ] chance
because it's all about this guy named
dooley yeah it's like yeah well that's
right references and there's like a
reference like the ragtime frog yeah
i cannot overemphasize how cool yeah she
was like yeah he's doing children
you could tell she's one of those girls
she was just the cool cool yeah like
yeah she's super funny even she didn't
think it was funny at all she like was
so she's into it and she's a great
actress
i think i fell in love with her when she
posted one music video i was like it's
over she's all the above uh and uh yeah
she was just like we got to work with
her for 30 minutes we made that thing
what if she got a boyfriend would you
guys roast this
see that's what i'm saying what are you
gonna do it'd be tough would be tough
but we'd support her i think
do you guys have do you guys have your
eye on the next possible we a lot of
people like will
pitch us on like
you need yeah i need to follow this
person next oh my god most of them are
like zendaya we might follow um
the stallone sisters fan account oh yes
just them though
just the fan i don't know how many more
subtle hints i could be drawing she's
like if you need just in case she can
well if haley gets her boyfriend just in
case that could be
and then let's have your people talk to
our people perfect i'm talking i don't
think i have any people so you can talk
to me so where do you guys see
long term where do you see friday beers
going
um
well right now we're like trying to
we're creating a little bit of like a
mini media company around friday beers
and what we want to do is like achieve
the
achieve the
i guess content that we've made on
instagram in every form of content and
it's not just the same as like just
taking that video you did and put it on
another platform or do a project with
what you already have made but it's just
taking like our voice and sense of humor
and trying to make the same stuff for
like tick tock and youtube and like
hopefully like tv shows and movies
make events like have events for people
which we've done a handful of cell
apparel like we have this whole music
project that we're doing with dj press
play yeah i mean like the the
media company is like kind of the big
overarching uh
goal but for for
jack and i yeah the dream is you know
writing like the next great tv show
right comedy like that's our dream you
were saying you like sunny and
philadelphia yeah
basically yeah we want to make our
version of it's always sunny just like a
timeless sitcom
um we've always said there hasn't been a
really good comedy show in a very long
time even movies wise like there's
nothing like
there's nothing like and that's what we
want to do yeah
our personal passion is that yeah
thank god there's someone that's doing
it we're trying to be uh we're on the
mission but it's hard like we gotta it's
tricky it takes a long time and but you
guys are doing it different which is
cool it's something that i haven't seen
before and you're taking a completely
different route as opposed to
like the bar stool
do you guys get annoyed when you do get
compared to barstool sports uh only
because the tone is very different right
um
they're kind of like the bullies and and
we're
not so uh
to wrap up the show yeah sophie and i
wanted to do a little rapid fire
question okay segment with you guys
we're going to list off the questions
first answer that comes from do nothing
i don't think quickly on my feet at all
perfect so why don't we start with you
and then you answer right after
you're ready
yeah
if you were a chair who would you like
to sit on you
uh
lizzo
excellence that's actually cancer yeah
you can elaborate if you want how does a
chair who would i want to sit on me
um trying to think it was like a nice
comfy butt that's the lizzo
[Applause]
all right first word that comes to mind
when you hear unwaxed go don't think
vagina nice nice nice porn
excellent all right
what are you winning gold at in the
olympics for
i'm winning gold at 100 meter dash
nice i'm not fast well it could be
anything honestly it could be anything
yeah
anything you want i am winning i am
winning gold for
uh
[Music]
100 meter dash
um
i'm probably winning i'm winning gold
for like
record number of uh
like episodes if it's always sunny
watched oh there's like a competition
for that yeah yeah yeah you probably are
the guinness world
yeah how many would you say i think i've
seen it every episode of the first six
seasons like 20 times each
i think we should get guinness guinness
can verify yeah honestly yeah i'm sure i
thought you're gonna say the most bent
thumb oh yeah [ __ ] yeah that's okay
oh yeah so here guys a hundred angry
deadly toddlers are coming towards you
to attack they have nothing in mind
except to kill you yeah
how do you defend yourself
uh weapons involved yes what weapon
would you like i mean this would be
amazing i would take an aluminum
baseball bat
yeah like black magic
you can do it you can choose any weapon
any weapon baseball you really can feel
that you have to just defend yourself 32
inch 29 ounce black magic uh bat and i
would just start off
these are feral toddlers like they don't
they're not normal like yeah
it's okay that they're getting there's a
little mini and wise exactly yeah
uh can can we use like fictional weapons
yeah
of course anything okay gravity gravity
gravity
okay excellent what is your guilty
pleasure
uh
my guilty pleasure would be
um
uh what's the show that i like to watch
that i don't tell anybody about it's a
reality show
um i kind of do like when olivia watches
the kardashians i'll i'll sit down and
watch that with her good husband yeah
that's the husbandly duty and i'll leave
my more explicit ones uh off the podcast
that's nice of course i feel like i had
a good guilty pleasure i can't remember
it now i also have i also have one like
it's not good
i'm not guilty about it but i'm made to
feel guilty about it by others like
eating disgusting food like like what
type of food just like every type like i
could i could probably eat like a
hundred dollars for the mcdonald's like
oh wow i don't think
i don't qualify
i don't qualify chick-fil-a's disgusting
i think it's beautiful food yeah i could
eat that every single day like pigging
out on fast food
you're a fat sales guy
yes yeah yes i could do any of that
stuff not texas yeah and i don't feel
guilty about it but everybody should
make sure you feel about that if you
feel good that's all that matters
all right what is your answer you've had
time
i was like the worst answer ever like i
like to show you like oh that is like
you would like you
should it's not because you like that
[ __ ] here's the thing
i want to be stopped like that's why he
relates
yeah
i wore this before joe wore it now
i already finished it who are you
stalking i don't like it
i'm not like smart enough to be all
right uh can you be too obvious yeah um
outside your house i can see you in my
bedroom is that from max
i don't want to be honest but it was
i did see a hat outside my window all
right a conspiracy theory you believe in
uh conspiracy theory
um i'm not familiar with many of them oh
we love conspiracy theories here uh name
summit
all right all right chuck e cheese
conspiracy
whenever you have slices left at the
table and the customer leaves they take
the slices bring it back to the kitchen
puzzle them back together put some more
cheese reheat it it's actually true you
can find photos sure buy it all right
that's i'm trying to stay away from like
the dangerous ones we also have lizard
people people believe that like the ones
that control the world yeah are lizards
dasani okay well yeah i mean like i
guess this isn't really conspiracy
because it's like confirmed like aliens
exist and like that's no people think
that's conspiracy too
it's not have you ever seen um
acknowledge unacknowledged wait i
haven't i was gonna see it i heard it's
good it is sick okay i believe in aliens
like fully confirmed okay so then that's
frozen you know what i i
actually have a good alien question this
is a pretty lame conspiracy but uh
i think the
mlb
majority baseball is like a fraudulent
organization for allowing the houston
astros to cheat and
cheat their way into like the world
series that's the news
they got rid of the manager but they
didn't take any sanctions against like
any of the players right there's like
one politician that's not a conspiracy
theory it's a conspiracy to think that
they like so he's passionate about it
let those players off the hook and i
think like carlos grey jose altuve and
alex bregman and george springer should
like never be allowed to play baseball
again and i think they cheated the
yankees out of a world series and that's
the most the political cause i'm most
passionate about
because rob manfred is an absolute clown
for doing that so yeah you clown yeah
i'm sticking with aliens
would you rather be a clown for a living
or never drink beer again
like that is yours like that is your job
or you can never have a sip of beer
again be a clown yeah it's either you
have what what's yeah what kind of clown
how many times how many days i work in
maybe like four days a week and i go
like kids birthday parties yeah yeah
yeah but yeah forever well clowning can
take many forms you've seen baskets yeah
for the show no yeah
clown is a pretty refined art yeah you
are the classic creep clown on the
street you're not like a parisian no no
no no no no no maybe you're being a mime
you can't talk like all right so you're
literally like a hack like kid's
birthday party yeah yeah yeah like the
guy who was getting hammered
like your suit smells like cigarettes
but you can drink beer so that's the
place
it seems like in the joker they had a
pretty cool like locker room vibe with
all this camaraderie yeah finally a
community that i feel like died in the
locker room
um yeah
yeah yes we're gonna get exposed if we
don't say the cloud answer oh no i mean
i i'm kind of like getting convincing
myself i'm like the clown looks like i'm
gonna say yeah
all of your followers would disown you
yeah i chose the other option all right
i'll be a clown in four days a week
though three days a week come and suck
down
would you rather know how you will die
or when you're going to die
uh
when
as my friend saggs would say i've
already seen how i'm going to die oh
great
uh i'm not scared oh nice i would choose
if
when yeah if you know how you're gonna
it helps you manage paranoia actually
because anxiety is like uncertainty but
if you're certain about like well two
weeks from now boys
time to live or you're like or you're
like oh i'm gonna die in like 60 years
like let's [ __ ] actually yeah now
that i'm thinking about it knowing when
you're gonna die it's a great advantage
okay do you feel like you're gonna be
more motivated i would manage my entire
life accordingly i'd be like you know i
if i don't have to worry about being
past 52 i'm just like all right i've got
you know 25 years now i can like manage
well i feel like that's because you
aren't afraid of death no i don't fear
it and i don't think i'm afraid of it
either like i think a lot of people yeah
the thought of it freaks them out but
i'm like yeah i feel like i've done good
like frank reynolds would say when i die
just throw him in the trash is it fun
i've never been in love because it's fun
so depressing right now
all right this is such a weird question
but i'm curious so you've seen those
shitty pools that are above the ground
they're like
yeah yeah so how long do you think that
would take you to drink the whole thing
of what substance yeah water
in that pool of chlorine water yes but
you're not going to die
no maybe not chlorine we could just
click it's fresh water
i'll suck that thing down in five days
the whole thing five days at full yeah
five days yeah you're gonna die honestly
like a super like crunchy like health
person would be like well that's
technically how much water you should be
drinking every two days
so i think i could if i was determined i
could i could do some i could do the
damage on that five days all right yeah
i don't think i'd ever finish it oh yeah
you don't really he's like i would die i
drowned before
okay final question this is an important
one i would like to put other substances
in that book you can pull it you can put
like uh what's it called crystal light
in there well i'm just saying like i
would put like a thing of a
okay final question if your belly button
was a real button what would you want it
to do
uh jetpack um boots so i could like fire
straight in the air like yeah yeah
you have that answer that was really
quick the check guys see you there
what a teleportation
this is not me pandering to
our followers but a beer a beer me
button or you press it and then a beer
just shows up but where would it have to
be from your right no it says something
someone is like just calls like someone
brings you a beer oh it's like a
service so it's like an uber eats for
beers yeah you press and you get back to
this profile anything can happen
anything could happen
money like [ __ ] button
automatic
that's pretty good
i love it i see where both your heads
are at i feel like i still think i i
would be a toss-up between the [ __ ]
of the job
i feel like the jet boots would get you
the [ __ ] right so i don't know it's
true yeah i don't think anyone or the
other baby you want to see me do the jet
boots thing again
he's like yeah
um thank you guys so much for joining us
today
thanks for having us
hopefully we can all have a beer
together soon we had one here today so
that's your week if you have a date you
guys what should we go to tagalong yeah
i think we should
work groucho marx disguises yeah
everyone should go this whole crew
yeah everyone's coming everyone in the
studio um look at the next table there's
nine people with newspapers okay
everyone are you guys public are you
guys public on social media besides yeah
we're public yeah you know a lot of
flowers yes put your instagrams in put
your taglines in uh well at friday.beers
first of all
do it at friday.beers and my personal
instagram is at jbfresh2
jb fred's it's way cooler than mine jb
fresh mine's uh it's just my first name
and my middle name which is maxwell
reddington
it's really white yeah it's
perfect i wonder if i'll get some
followers
oh yeah well thank you guys so much for
joining us if you're not having a beer
on friday then what are you even doing
here we'll see you guys next week bye
[Music]
you